اسعد الله مسائكم بكل خير مشاهدينا نحييكم
الى بانوراما كالعاده نناقش ابرز ملفات
اليوم في ملف في هذا المساء الذي
نناقشه عبر اجزاء وعبر نقاط معينه هل تنجح
قمه العشرين في انقاذ العالم من حرب
العالميه الثالثه او من انزلها على الصراع
النووي بسبب الازمه الاوكرانيه في نفس هذا
الاطار ماذا سيقدم قمه العشرين من حلول
لمواجهه ازمات الطاقه والغذاء ومنكودا
يبدو محتوما
بدات اعمله قمه العشرين في جزيره بالي
الاندونيسيه بمشاركه رؤساء وقيادات دول
عدا في ظل غياب الرئيس
تاتي القمه التي تنظم تحت شعار التعافي
معا التعافي بشكل اقوى تاتي وسط تحديات
صعبه
على جدول اعمال القمه بالاضافه الى
تداعيات الازمه في اوكرانيا والتعاون
الدولي والتحول رقمي وازمه المناخ وشدد
رئيس الاندونيسيه
افتتاح القمه على انه يجب تجربه علميه
اخرى معتبران انه يجب انهاء الحرب
في ما قال مسؤول امريكي
ولا المجموعه تتفقد خلال محادثاتها مؤخرا
على انه ينبغي ادانه حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا باقوى العبارات الممكنه وفيما
تضم مجموعه ال 20 روسيا فمن غير المرجح
توصل الى توافق في الاراضي الصراف
اوكرانيا وسط مخاوف من اندلاع صراع نووي
[موسيقى]
نناقشه هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا من موسكو
لانا في العلاقه الدوليه في مدرسه
الاقتصاد العليا من ابوظبي عبر عزون
المتحدث باسم السفاره الاوكرانيه في دوله
الامارات ومن باريس اسامه حريري المحلل
السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي
ان ابدا من باريس معك سيد اسامه سيد اسامه
هذه القمه تاتي في الواقع في ظروف خاصه
واستثنائيه تاتي في ظروف يعيش العالم فيها
انقسامات جو السياسيه
قد تؤثر على ما يرشح عن هذه القمه ولكن مع
كل هذا الى اي مدى ترى حظرتك بانه هناك
نوايا حقيقيه لايجاد حلول يمكن ان تنفذ
لانهاء هذه الازمه او هذه الازمات ومن بين
وابرزها على الاقل الظاهر همم من بينها
على الاقل ازمه اوكرانيا
الشئ والفعل او النتيجه شيء اخر الازمه
كبيره التي نعيشها اليوم طبعا هي ازمات
متعدده ربما تتلخص بازمه عالميه كبيره من
الركود من الركود من ضعف الاقتصادات من
الامن الغذائي من زياده الفقر في عده دول
من ازمه الطاقه كل هذه الازمات الصعبه جدا
ان يتم حلها في قمه يعني واحده وهي اليوم
قمه العشرين قمه هذه قمه ربما هي التمهيد
تمهيد لحل هذه الازمات كان فيها يعني عده
لقاءات ملفته للنظر خاصه اللقاء الذي تم
بين الرئيس الصيني والرئيس الامريكي والذي
يعني بحسب البعض كسر الجليد نوعا ما كان
هناك ايضا لقاء بين سجن بينك والرئيس
الوزراء الاسترالي طبعا كما قلت يعني حل
هذه الازمات كلها في هذه القمه لا اعتقد
اننا يعني ستصل الى نتيجه كبيره نحن
متجهون نحو ركود عالمي لا مفر منه ولكن
يعني اقل الايمان هو القيام بالجهود لحل
هذه الازمات والجهود تتم اولا عبر التعاون
ولهذا السبب يعني كان هناك على ما يبنيه
حقيقيه في هذه القمه لتعاون نوعا ما بين
الولايات المتحده والصين اولا وضع
الخلافات جانبا صحيح الولايات المتحده
والصين هناك منافسه شديده ولكن الاتفاق
قال كان على ان تكون هذه منافسه ولكن ليس
صداما بالضروره لان الصدام سيؤدي يعني الى
استفحال الامور اذا يمكننا القول ان هذه
القمه هي بالاحرى لتجنب صراعات اكثر لتجنب
الاسود ولكنها عمليا يعني لن تؤدي الى حال
حاله بين ليله وضحاها للمشاكل العظيمه نعم
نعم
على تعدادها والدخول في تفاصيلها ولكن هذه
القمه سبقتها دعوات في الواقع سواء من
الاتحاد الاوروبي او من حلف الاطلسي او من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه دعوات
لاوكرانيا
فتح مجال للتفاوض همم هل يمكن ان تكون هذه
القمه خطوه اولى لتنفيذ مثل هكذا او على
الاقل لبناء اليه معينه لامكانيه تنفيذ
مثل هكذا استراتيجيه
مشاهدينا الكرام
عوضوا ان ابدا من نقطه مهمه
دعونا نسمي الاشياء باسمائها الحقيقيه لان
هذه هي الطريقه الوحيده للبحث عن الاجابات
الصحيحه للاسئله الصعبه للغايه مطروحه على
جنب العالميه لا توجد ازمه هناك عدوان
روسي غير مباركه
من الحرب العدوانيه الاستعماريه الروسيه
كانت روسيا هي التي تحدث الامن العالمي
وتهدد اليوم الى الاسلحه النوويه وترجع
الى اهتزاز النووي في محطه الذكري انه
وتحول الاغذيه الى الاسلحه وتحول دم اجزاء
من اوكرانيا
وترتكب الجرائم العديده همم ويؤكد عن قمه
مجموعه 20 دولي شديده لروسيا ولا يمكن
اعتبار روسيا دوله كبرى في هذه الظروف
شوف الغياب عن هذا الحدث العالم جثير
العالم بوضوح انه لا يدعم هذا العدوان
الروسي والخطوه التاليه همم لابد من
اتخاذها هي زياده الدعم لاوكرانيه
لاستعاده سلامتها الاقليميه من الداخل الى
روسيا والتنظيم دفع التعويضات اذ تم فتح
الطريق الى ذلك امس من قبل الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده لتبنت القرار في هذه السنه
ومراقبه المسلمين الروس واجبار روسيا على
احترام ميثاق الامم المتحده ها هو الطريق
انطلاقا من الاسم الصحيح رضوان روسيا على
اوكرانيا
قد لا يتم توافق عليه قد لا يتم التوافق
الجماعي على همم
اثبات عدوان او كما ذكرت حضرتك عدوان روسي
على اوكرانيا بما ان روسيا همم مشاركه في
هذه القمه سيده همم
اوكي هل يمكن ان يكون هناك بدء فعلي
بامكانيه ايجاد حلول ضيفي يلقي باللوم على
روسيا يقول بان روسيا هي التي ليس فقط
انتهكات همم الباره الاوكراني ولكن الى
اليوم هي تنتهك هي اا تصاعد وهي لا تبذر
على الاقل او لا تبادر على الاقل بنوايا
حسنا لتهدئه كيف ترين حضرتك الموضوع
بالتاكيد قمه ال 20 هي قمه اقتصاديه ولكن
نلاحظ بان الطابع السياسي هو الذي كان
غالب بدءا من الاجتماع بين اداره الرئيس
الامريكي بعيدا مع الرئيس الصيني ونلاحظ
كان هناك تنفيذ احتقان كبير بين المعسكر
الشرقي والمعسكر الاوروبي الغربي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وايضا كان
هناك كلمه القاها زينسكي وكلمه ايضا لا
ظروف لذلك نلاحظ بان هذه القمه لم تاتي
بموجبها في حلول ايجابيه حلول حقيقيه انما
فعليا كان المحور الاساسي على الطاوله هو
المحور الروسي الاخراني وانا روسيا تستعمل
الغذاء والسلاح وايضا المحور الملف النووي
نلاحظ كان هناك اتفاق بالاجماع على عدم
تسييس الوضع عليه في استخدام ايه من الدول
الاسلحه النوويه او ان يكون هناك حرب
عالميه ثالثه هذا متفق عليه ولكن بالنسبه
لعدد قضايا من مختلفه عليها حتى بين وجهه
نظر الامريكي والصيني ومنها بان السياسه
العقوبات الغربيه الامريكيه ضد روسيا هي
من جعلت هناك تفاقم كبير في الاغذيه وايضا
في محور الطاقه العالميه وهناك ايضا كان
اقتراحات اوروبيه بوضع حد سقف معين لالتقى
الروسيه بالتالي تستفيد منها صحيح
لموضوع الطاقه والتغذيه ولكن لنبقى فقط في
موضوع تصعيد العسكري لان وكان الجهود
الاوروبيه تتجاه نحو همم امكانيه وقف
الاقتتال في هذه المرحله وهذا ما نفهمه من
الدعوات سواء الاوروبيه او الامريكيه هل
روسيا يمكن ان تقبل بمثل هكذا الماديات في
هذه المرحله
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد روسيا قد ترحبت بهذه
المفاوضات هناك الانفاوضات سريه تعقد بين
الجانب الامريكي والجانب الروسي لا يمكن
ان ننكرها هناك ضغط امريكي على حكومه لعقد
اتفاقيه مع روسيا وكان محور الفاصل هو
خيرسون كان هناك معلومات استخباراتيه
كبيره بان بحال انسحاب روسيا من خيرسون
سوف تتيح امريكا لاوكرانيا لبدء المفاوضات
السلام
معاهده السلام مع الجانب الروسي لذلك
نلاحظ بان هناك بوادر ايجابيه لاحلال
المفاوضات بين الجانب الغربي مع روسيا
ولكن بالمقابل لا يمكن ان نتنبا ان هذه
المفاوضات قد تكون ناجحه وايجابيه على
اكمل وجه وخاصه انا روسيا ترفض المطالب
الاوكرانيه ومنها انسحابها من اقليم دون
سيك ولوكانس هذا لا يمكن لروسيا ان تتعامل
مع هذه القضيه اما بالنسبه للخير ممكن
اعاده ترسيم الحدود بالتالي يوجد بعض
الاشكاليات والنقاط المختلفه عليها نعم
الجانبين ولكن نلاحظ بان هناك محاوله لفك
التعقيد والعقد الاساسيه لمحاوله الجذب
الانتباه الجانب الاوكراني والجانب الروسي
والجوز على الطاوله وهذا كله كان بيبدا من
قبل مبادره امريكيه سريه نلاحظ ان احد
لهذا التفسير
بالضبط ساعود لهذا التفصيل عن هذه
المفاوضات السريه همم وودت سماع رايك في
هذا الموضوع سيد جنين ولكن قبل متابعه
النقاش دعونا نلقي نظره كذلك على الصراعات
المستشريه في العالم والتي تثير المخاوف
في الواقع من انزلها حربا عالميه ثالثه
وربما ما هو اكثر من ذلك وهو الحرب
النوويه هل لدى قمه العشرين وقادتها
الفرصه لابعاد شبح هذه الكارثه متابعه
ونعود
جول
انا مقتنع الان انه قد حان وقت ايقاف
الحرب الروسيه مدمره وليس هناك اي اعذار
للتهديد
المسؤوليه تعني انه يجب علينا ان نسجل
الستار على الحرب واذا لن تنتهي فسيصعب
علينا ان نمضي قدما وان نحقق الاستقرار من
اجل مستقبل الاجيال القادمه يجب علينا الا
ندخل العالم في دهاليز الصراع او في حرب
بارده جديده
[موسيقى]
بكره بكره
عدوانيين للغايه والقوا باللوم على روسيا
في العدوان على اوكرانيا كما يسمونه كلما
تحدثوا عن العدوان غير المبرر كل ما تاكد
لجميع الاطراف ان هذا العدوان هو من صنعهم
نحن لا نرفض التفاوض مع اوكرانيا بل هي
التي ترفض ذلك وهذا ما يجعل التوسل الى
اتفاق امرا اصحاب
عمليه
التفاوض مع روسيا كما اكد على ذلك وزير
الخارجيه روس ياسر جلال حتى انا ضيف ستقول
بانه الموضوع خرج من ايدي الاكران هناك
مفاوضات سريه تقيمها روسيا مع واشنطن ومع
الغرب في العموم يعني الوضع قادر ان
يجعلكم تقفوا في يوم من الايام امام امر
واقع بمحاوله تهدئه يقبلها الغرب وتبقى
اوكرانيا خارج الموضوع
لماذا هناك رفض لهذا المفاوضات في هذه
المرحله
طب اذا تكلمنا عن امكانيه المفاوضات فيجب
ان يشير الى القصص الصاروخي اليوم القصف
الصاروخ الارهابي على المدن الالكترونيه
عن طريق
هذا الفصل خلال قمه 20 تظل لروسيا من جديد
جميع قاده دول العالم الذي اجددت فكره
الحوار ومحادثات السلام مع هذه الدوله
المعتاده من الضروري ان نظهر اخيرا ان
الاتحاد الروسي لا يقترح اجراء المفاوضات
السلامه لكنه يطرح انذارات
يطلب ان نتنازل عن ارضنا وشعبنا
ووطن الامر غير مقبول وغير مقبول وحتى
الان ااه تنتهي همم جميع المحاولات همم
استرداد روسيا همم هذه الدوله همم ضربات
الصاروخيه على المباني السكنيه وقتل
المدنيين ولهذا السبب وانا اقول ونحن نقول
يعني مره اخرى وقفوا عن اقتراح اقران
للقبول بالاندرات الروسيه غير معروفات
روسيا
التي تقترح لنا الحوار معه يعني دون
انسحاب الوطن روسيا من ارادنا لا يمكن
ايقاف هذا الارهاب وهذا الحرب العدوانيه
الا بقوه اسلحه
مبنيها الغرب وكان هناك تلميح من حظر
تكبير ان هناك تغير في الموقف الغربي تجاه
ما يحدث سيد اسامه همم هل هناك تغيير في
الموقف الاوروبي يمكن ان يتبلور بشكل او
باخر من خلال هذه القمه
نعم بالضبط يعني في الموقف الغربي بشكل
عام بدانا نشهد ذلك من اللقاء الاخير الذي
جمع مستشار ان القومي الامريكي جي 7
اللي بعدها قالت بشكل واضح ان على ما يبدو
تشيك سلفنت ضغطت نوعا ما على زنسكي للقبول
بمفاوضات يعني واقعيه او مطالب واقعيه من
اجل المفاوضات مع روسيا هناك اليوم من بعد
طبعا بخصوص يعني هذه قمه العشرين اليوم
التي تتركز على موضوع الاقتصاد العالم
معنا جدا من ازمه 19 وبعدها دخل مباشره في
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا بالتالي القوه
بشكل عام القوه العالميه اليوم ليس من
مصلحتها ان ان تست- همم تدوم هذه الحرب
الجاريه حاليا حتى الصين يعني ليس فقط
الغرب بيدفع باتجاه مفاوضات بين اوكران
الروس بل حتى الصين كان هناك اتصال
مباشر
صباح اليوم قال فيه بشكل واضح انك ادعم
المبادره الفرنسيه لخفض التصعيد فوكرانيا
وحتى ان تشيجنبين بحسب البيان الفرنسي دعم
مباشره لمحادثات سلام بين الاوكران وبين
الروس بالتالي هناك جو عام استنتجناه في
هذه القمه في قمه العشرين
بين الروس
ونحن فقدنا نسبه لا باس بها من ارضنا كيف
نفاوض في هذه المرحله والروس لازال
وموجودون على اي اساس يحفز الغرب اوكرانيا
الى تفاوض همم غير مبني على شروط على
الاقل يراها الاوكرانيون بانها شروط
اساسيه
يعني هذه وجهه نظر الاوكرانيه للاسف يعني
اوكرانيا صحيح هي
المعتده عليها من قبل روسيا روسيا اشتاحت
اوكرانيا وهذا امر واضح جدا ولكن اليوم هي
يعني اوكرانيا ربما تقع في النصف هي فقط
وسيله ربما نوعا ما لهذه الحرب الشامله
بين الغرب من جهه وروسيا من جهه اخرى
بالنهايه الدوله التي تحدد شروط هذه
المفاوضات بنهايه هي الولايات المتحده هي
التي تدعم اوكرانيا عسكريه وهي التي ايضا
يعني طبعا بفضل الجنود الاكران استطاعوا
ان يحرروا هذه الاراضي ولكن قبل كل شيء
ايضا بفضل الاسلحه الامريكيه بالتالي
اليوم نحن نقبل على فصل الشتاء وفي يعني
في فتره الشتاء من المعروف جدا ان كلا
الطرفان لا يستطيعان فعلا ان يتقدم معه
على ساحه المعركه ستكون الشتاء سيكون طويل
جدا لا نتوقع القوات الاوكرانيه ان تتقدم
ولا ايضا القوات الروسيه بالتالي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تدفع بالمفاوضات هذا لا
يعني ان المفاوضات ستم بين ليله وضحاها
دائما
بادئ هذه
الارضيه بالتحقيق الارضيه لهذه المفاوضات
همم استعملت مصطلح وسيله باختصار شديد
يعني همم كنتم وسيله بيد
الغربران يسبب التسامح عليها او ان او
وسيله يعني في صراعات او ستسمح بالدفع الى
القلوب لا تصب في مصلحتها هي كلمات
ومحدثات سخيفه النصيحه النصيحه للجميع
بالترك هذا التصور القديم عن اوك دوله
تتعرض للضغط او الاشجار
الجوانيا
وهذا الموقف تتاكده شركائنا الرئيسيون
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي نحن
اليوم نخلق تاريخا جديدا مع الشركائنا
الذين يقفون الى جانب همم هذا هو يعني هذا
الموضوع
السيده لنا الغريب في الموضوع نحن بصدد
مناقشه امكانيه ايجاد حلول ولكن روسيا
تصعد وكان ذكر منذ قليل السيد فرجانين
الصواريخ الروسيه على اوكرانيا وذكرها حتى
في ما قبل همم ذكرتها القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه يتحدث عن اكثر من 100 صاروخ
روسي باتجاه اوكرانيا حتى مولدوفا تحدثت
عن انقطاع الكهرباء نتيجه
المنبعثه من القصف الروسي في داخل
الاوكرانيا انبعثت هذه الغازات هكذا تكون
منذ فعلى الاقل فما الذي يريده بوتين من
خلال هذا القصف هل هي رساله تتزامن مع
انطلاق هذه القمه ما رسالته في هذه الحاله
اكيد يمكن فصل المفاوضات عن ما يرجع على
الارض الواقع من عمليات عسكريه الان تجري
هناك بالتاكيد صراع عسكري بين الجيش
الاوكراني والجيش الروسي مثلا في اقليم
لوكاس بالتالي يمكن فصل اقليم خرسا على
الاقليم
الذي يمكن ان نقول بانه يخضع للمفاوضات
انه مقابل بقيه لقالم لا تخضع تلك
الاقاليم هي تابعه للاتحاد الفدرالي
الروسي بالتالي روسيا ترد على ايه ضربه
موجهه تحت تلك عليه
لن يساعد حتى الموجودين او المشاركين الى
هذه القمه لمحاوله طرح اليه همم يمكن ان
تكون همم سليمه لايجاد حل
بالتاكيد ولكن لا يمكن لروسيا ان تعمل على
تجميد الصراع مقابل ان يكون هناك تقدم
اوكراني كبير هذه القمه لم تحرز اي تقدم
ايجابي بالنسبه للصعيد الروسي بالنسبه
لاتفاقيه مثلا الحبوب والموانئ روسيا قال
سوف تفكر في الموضوع وسوف تمضي على اقرار
اما ان يكون هناك يعني تتالي لهذه
الاتفاقيه او ان يكون هناك توقيف لهذه
الاتفاقيه بنسبه الموضوع ومشروع الطاقه لم
يكن هناك اي تقدم واحتراز ايجابي بالنسبه
لاعفاء روسيا بعد العقوبات مقابل ان تعطي
الدول الغربيه المواد الطاقه ان ما كان
هناك بحث عن بديل مثل الطاقه الاحفوريه
وغيرها وهذا يحتاج الى لعام 2050 بالتالي
كل ما بقدر على هذه القمه هي اماني
ومشاريع وتناولت الحد السياسي ولن تتناول
الركود العالم هي الاقتصادي الذي يعاني
منه العالم منه يعني قبل حتى خمسه اعوام
وليس في الحرب الروسيه الاوك بالتالي
روسيا لا ترى بان القمه ال 20 هي قمه قد
اعطتها بوادر ايجابيه او اعطتها مثلا حلول
لذلك روسيا الان تتصرف وفق العقليه التي
تفكر بها وان قادره فعليه على التعامل مع
اقتصادها وفق الدول التي تتوافق مع
الاقتصاد الروسي وخاصه في شرق اسيا وكان
هناك تناول موضوع مهم جدا وهو التسليح
الشرقه فبالتالي هذه القمه لم تحرز اي
حلول ايجابيه انما اعرضت على مواقف وعرضت
ملفات صعبه معقده وتمنوا الجميع ان يكون
هناك مفاوضات سلام وهو في الفعل تسعى اليه
روسيا وخاصه الشتاء قد اتى يعني وهذا ما
سيكون هناك صعوبه للعمليه العسكريه ولكن
لا يمكن ان نتحدث بين قمه العشرين اتت
بحلول او ايجابيه او انها تعمل فعليا على
احلال المساله الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه
او احلال الازمات الاقتصاديه
القليل من الوقت صحيح ولكن نترك فقط
صيدلانا القليل من الوقت لهذه القمه لانه
هي انطلقت اليوم تمتد اليومين حتى يوم 17
فربما ربما اا نشهد شيء ولكن قلت بان
روسيا تتعامل مع الميدان
بفصله عن واقع همم الحضور في مجموعه ال 20
او واقع ما يمكن ان يناقش في مجموعات
العشرين همم سيد يعني همم تقول بان روسيا
يعني همم
تتعامل مع هذا الموضوع اييي راس او بفكر
عسكري وانتم تتعاملون مع هذا الموضوع بفكر
يتعلق اكثر بشركاء كن ذكرتهم شركاء في اول
حديثك وفيما بعد كنت واجهت لهم كلمه
بالقول بانه يجب ان لا يقنعونا بوجوب
التفاوض هل هناك احساس بالخزلان في هذه
المرحله ممن اعتبرتهم شركاء في مرحله من
المراحل
الاتحاد الاوروبي
وامريكا واليابان وكثير منهم يعني كل هذه
الشركاء همم
قرار الجمعيه العامه اسمها العنوان اخرى
انه انت ممكن همم تشوف كل هذه الشركاء
يعني عددهم 140 دوله لا لا اقدر
ولكن 140 دوله قرار جمعيه العامه
اكتفي بهذا الجانب اود شكرا لكم
المتحدث باسم السفاره الاوكرانيه في دوله
الامارات ومن موسكو لنا بدافانا البحث في
العلاقه الدوليه في مدرسه الاقتصاد العليا
شكرا لكم بالنسبه للاستاذ اسامه حريري
تفضل بالبقاء معنا لاستكمال النقاش في امم
شق اخر يختص بالاقتصاد بالطاقه بالغذاء
بكل الجوانب الاخرى التي يمكن ان تناقش في
هذه القمه